you have everything you need to create
the life that you ultimately want right
now
[Music]
a lot of people will say you know our
greatest asset is time from a spiritual
minimalism perspective your greatest
asset is actually presence because you
can have all the time in the world but
if you're never present with that time
then is it really that valuable I think
we get in our heads about things like
purpose and meaning and we're sitting
around waiting to be struck by lightning
when it comes to your heart voice you
really only have one option you can't go
to me you can't go to any psychic or
therapist and they can sit you down and
say your purpose is to dot dot dot only
you know what that is but you have to